are you ready to explode the amazing
world of operators in Java if you are a
beginner this is a great place to start
and if you are an experienced Java
programmer you might be surprised by
what you learn
so what are operators in Java they are a
group of characters that allows you to
perform mathematical and logical
operations on data types like strengths
integers and bullions that means
operators allow you to do everything
from simple addition and subtraction to
Advanced mathematical calculations but
that's just the beginning there are so
many different operators in Java and
each one has its own unique
functionality in this video we'll take a
look at the most popular operators
present in Java and you'll learn
everything you need to know about how to
use them what they do and how they can
make your coding life a whole lot easier
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
get notified whenever we drop a new
video if you are eager to enhance your
coding skills across various domains of
software engineering you might want to
consider a Caltech coding boot camp with
a state-of-the-art Caltech coding
bootcamp you can learn to code and
become a full stack developer within 6
months get fully immersed in this
accelerated coding bootcamp and become a
valued software engineer ready to take
on any challenges on the job
the key benefits of this program include
caltex atme bootcamp completion
certificate Caltech ctme Circle
membership online convocation by Caltech
ctme program director portfolio building
on GitHub up to 17 CEUs from Caltech
ctme
and master classes from Caltech ctme
instructors there are many more other
key features this bootcamp covers the
basic of several different Frameworks
including spring boot web services
servlets and jsps MVC JavaScript mongodb
and much more these skills will Empower
you to kick start your career as a
versatile full stack developer so take
advantage of this opportunity the course
link is provided in the description box
below keep watching this fun interactive
and informative video on Java operators
and by the end you will be using Java
operators like a pro so let's get
started let's get started with today's
topic which is about operators in Java
when we talk about operators in Java
there are multiple types of operators
like assignment operators arithmetic
operators unary operators then we have
conditional operators and logical
operators and we also have bitwise
operators and we will cover all of these
operators one by one we will understand
what what these operators are and how
they work and we will also look at a
demonstration of it so let's get started
the first operators we are going to
discuss is about arithmetic operators
and assignment operators and we will
also see if we can cover unary operators
so when we talk about assignment
operators I have again opened the
official Java docs here if we understand
assignment operators we have been using
this operators all the while in all of
the demos so far and the basic idea is
very simple whenever you assign a value
to a variable you use the assignment
operator which is nothing but the equal
sign we have already covered this in
multiple demos so I will not cover this
as part of the demo but what I'm going
to cover in detail is about these
arithmetic operators so arithmetic
operators are basically used to perform
any kind of arithmetic operation on a
Java program it can be an addition
operation it can be a subtraction
operation it can be a multiplication
operation a division operation or an
operation by which you can find the
remainder of the division so we will
look at each of these uh with an example
and as you can see the symbols are
expectedly what you generally use in
mathematics so you see the the plus sign
here which is for addition you see the
minus sign which is for subtraction you
see the star sign which is for
multiplication you see the slash sign
which is for division and you see the
percentage sign which is for finding the
remainder of a division so let's see an
example of each of these and how we can
use them in a Java program
so for the arithmetic operations I have
prepared a demonstration of it in the
Eclipse IDE again I'm using the same
Java project which I have shown you we
created in our previous lectures so I
will for all the demonstrations I will
just continue on the same project so
again the way to create a class Remains
the Same exactly the same as how I
covered in the previous lecture in the
hello world program where we created a
class so here also I created a class I
named the class as arithmetic demo and I
have a public static void main method
inside this particular class and I have
basically tried to demonstrate each of
the operation so let's start with the
additional operation first so I create
an integer variable here named as result
and then I try to use the addition
operator to make this variable store the
result of this Edition so it's a simple
one plus two you can also create two
different variables for one and two
let's say X equal to 1 and y equal to 2
and you can also do int result equal to
X Plus y it will have the same effect
but just for Simplicity I have put the
literal numbers here so result is
storing the the expression value of 1
plus 2 and then I am printing this value
here you can see I am printing the
result variable here with using system
dot out dot println then I'm storing
this result into a variable into a new
variable original result with using the
assignment operator and then I'm trying
to subtract something from it so now I'm
saying result equal to result minus 1 it
means whatever the current value of
result is subtract minus 1 from that
value so the value was 3 here and here 3
minus 1 becomes 2 so the new value of
result becomes 2 the original result
still holds 3 because it is storing the
old value the new value of result has
now become 2 so I'm printing the
original result and then what I'm doing
that I'm again assigning the new result
which is 2 to the original result so now
original result and result both are at 2
then I move ahead and I try to
demonstrate the multiplication operation
so I take the same variable result and I
say multiply it by two so whatever the
value of result was which at this place
should be 2 multiply that value by 2 so
2 into 2 the new value of result should
become 4 after this multiplication
operation and again I'm assigning the
value of original result to this
particular variable and then I'm
showcasing the fourth mathematical
arithmetic operation which is division
so you can see result by 2 here so
basically whatever the current value of
result is I am dividing that value by 2
so 4 divided by 2 should become 2 so
again the new value of the result
variable should become 2 then I am
printing the value and again storing the
value back into the original result then
the next operation is again an addition
operation where I whatever the value of
result is at this particular point which
is 2 add 8 to that particular value so
the new result value becomes 10 and then
I'm printing that particular value again
assigning the original result to the
result and then to showcase the
remainder operation I am doing result we
call this particular operator as mod or
modulus so result modulus 7 so the
current value here is in this case would
be 10 so I'm saying 10 mod 7 so 10 mod 7
would become 3 because if we divide 10
by 7 the remainder should be 3 and this
modulus operator is used to calculate
the remainder of a division operation so
that 3 will be stored in this result
variable and then we print that
particular variable so that is what I'm
doing if I take you back up there I will
just minimize this window and this
window as well so if I take you by back
to the starting I am doing an addition
first here at line seven then I am doing
a subtraction at line 12 then I'm doing
a multiplication at line 17 and a
division at line 22 and then again an
addition at line 27 and then our modulus
at line 32 and I'm printing the
respective values so let us run this
program and see what results do we get
so I right click I go to run as I go to
Java application there is also a
shortcut for it if you want to use the
shortcut you can use that so I click on
this and the output is is displayed here
so you can see let me bring this output
back to its original position yeah I
just dragged it here to the top to the
bottom so if you start from the top and
see what all results did we get printed
so line 9 says 1 plus 2 equal to the
value of result so 1 plus 2 equal to at
this particular point the result will
value was 3 because 1 plus 2 equal to 3
moving on the next variable here is
minus so the current value was 3 we said
3 minus 1 which becomes 2 and we store
the value of result or 3 into this
result variable and we print that value
at line 14. so original result plus
original result is 3 then a string here
minus 1 equal to so this is just a
string and then the actual current
result value which is 2 so far so good
we move ahead and then at line 19 we are
multiplying the current value of result
by 2 and again displaying the original
result and the current value so 2 is the
original result here because here 3
minus 1 had become 2 so original result
value was to multiply that by 2 becomes
4 then moving on to the line 24 2 by 4
by 2 should become 2 so 4 by 2 equals 2
the current value of result then again
and moving on to the next variable at
line 29 now the result value should
become 10 because 2 plus 8 is 10 and
again we are printing the original
result and then the current result value
so the original result was 2 then we
added 8 to it and the new result value
had become 10 which is coming from this
particular variable moving on to line 34
we are again printing the original
result which was 10 here and then we are
saying this particular string which is
modulus 7 and the current value of
result is coming from this expression
which is 10 modulus 7 and like I said
modulus or mod operation is basically
used to calculate the remainder of a
division operation which so 10 divided
by 7 remainder is 3 so that becomes 3
and that's why you see the value 3. so
this is a demonstration to show you how
we can use the addition multiplication
subtraction Division and modulus
operators which are all the edit
automatic operators engineering
operators so when we talk about unary
operators technically they are also
arithmetic operators but they provide us
a shorthand or they have a more advanced
meaning so if you see on the screen
these are the unary operators we call
them as generic plus unary minus
increment Operator decrement Operator
and logical complement operator so when
we talk about the engineering plus
operator basically it is used to
indicate a positive value so whatever
value you are having it will just make
that number as positive number you might
be wondering that this plus has an
addition meaning as well right which we
saw in the previous example yes that's
correct but when we use that addition
symbol we use that between two variables
but when we talk about Unity operators
they are used with a single variable
that is why the name unary because they
are used with a single variable they
require only one operand so generally
plus basically makes any number positive
usually minus negates an expression and
makes that number negative increment
operator increments the value by plus
one decrement operator decreases the
value by minus 1 and logical complement
operator inverts the value of the
expression from True to false or false
to True let's understand this with the
help of an example so I have created a
class here called unary demo and I have
a static void main method here and I
have created a variable called result
and the first example is about using
unity plus so I'm creating a variable
called as result assigning the value as
1 and just putting 1 plus in front of it
which makes this as positive value
though we can argue that this also has
the same effect as this and yes that is
true but in case if this value was
written as something like minus 1
instead of plus then then we could
basically make that number positive by
just putting Plus in front of it so
that's basically the power of unity
operators and that's how you generally
use Unity operators so I'll just put it
back to plus one the next example is
about decrement operators so the current
value of result was 1 because we did
this now we are saying result minus
minus which means whatever the value of
result is just decrement it by 1. so the
current value was 1 so now the new value
of result after this evaluation becomes
0. so at line 14 we print the current
value of result which is 0. moving on at
line 16 we are using the increment plus
plus operator here which means whatever
the current value of result is just
increment it by 1. so the current value
of result was 0 till this line so it
becomes 1 because this means increment
by 1. so line 18 will basically print
that value 1 and then at line 20 I'm
using the unary minus operator which
means whatever the value of result is
just negate it just put a negative in
front of it just make that number
negative so if I just say minus result
the current value of result was 1 so it
became minus 1 and then to showcase the
negation operation I created a Boolean
variable named it as success assign the
value of this variable as false and
printed the value of success variable as
is first and then print the value of
success with a negation in front of it
with an exclamation mark which will
basically flip the value or invert the
value of a Boolean variable so if this
was false line 28 should print true if
this was true line 28 should print false
in this case this is false so the line
28 should print true so let's right
click on this and run this program and
see if we get the expected output and
yes we see the output here so let's try
to interpret the output now the line 10
should print 1 yes then line 14 should
print 0 we see 0 here line 18 should
print 1 because we use the increment
plus plus so 0 plus 1 became 1 then we
use the unary minus operator so the
value should become -1 yes we see minus
1 here and then for Boolean variable we
should see first of all
because the value is printed as is and
then we are printing a negated value so
we should flip the value from false to
true and yes it is printing the value as
true so this was about unary operators
now when we talk about this increment
and decrement operators what if I put
this particular value in front of result
what effect is that going to happen
let's analyze that part as well so for
that I have prepared a separate demo
again I've created a class called
pre-post demo and it has a public static
void main method I'm declaring an
integer variable I with the value as 3
so the I becomes 3 here and then I'm
saying I plus plus as we have already
seen in the unary demo example this
should increment the value of 3 to 4 so
it will print 4 expected right then at
line number nine I am putting this plus
plus in front of I now what will happen
now it is going to increment the value
of IE and then and basically assigning
the value of I so the whole difference
between I plus plus and plus plus I is
that in this case the value of I is
assigned first and increment later in
this case the value of I is incremented
first and assigned later so here the
value from 4 becomes 5 so at line 11 if
you see if we print I it will print 5
because we have we are saying that first
increment the value and then update the
value of I so increment happens on I
equal to 4 and I becomes 5. at line
number 13 it becomes more interesting
because here inside the system.out.print
Ln statement itself I am saying plus
plus I now what will happen like I
explained first the value will be
incremented and then the value will be
assigned so before printing the value is
getting incremented so the value from 5
becomes 6 here at line 13 but if I try
to do this now I am saying first assign
the value of I and then increment it so
I at this line is still 6 because I has
already been assigned 6 and as the post
increment says if we put this plus plus
after the variable it means that you are
first assigning the value and then
incrementing the value so anything which
happens after line 15 the value of I
will become 7 but at line 15 the value
of I is still 6 because we are using a
post increment operator so the value is
still assigned to I as is and then
incremented and when we do
system.out.println the assigned value is
printed not the incremented value so
like I said after line 15 the value of I
will become incremented by 1 and it will
become 7. so hope you understood this
example or and the difference between
the pre-increment and post increment
remember the thumb rule that if we put
plus plus before a variable like at line
number nine the value will be
incremented first and then assigned so
at line 13 the updated value will be
printed because the first we are doing
the increment and then we are printing
the value for assigning the value
similarly at line 15 we are first
printing the value and then incrementing
the value so when the value is printed
at line 15 the old value 5 will be
printed but after line 15 the new value
of I will be accessible to the program
so let's right click on this and run
this program and now if we see the
values we assigned I to 3 we did a post
increment here so I becomes 4 we print
the value of I so here the value of I is
4 you see 4 here then at line line nine
we are saying plus plus I so four plus
one becomes 5 though this is is a
pre-increment but since we are not
printing this plus I as is it does not
have any any change so the value of 4
becomes 5 at line 11 we print 5 then at
line 13 we are saying plus plus I which
means increment the value of I first and
then assign it so the value of 5 becomes
6 and then I gets updated and printed
similarly at line 15 first the value of
I is assigned and printed and then
incremented so at line 15 the value is
still 6 you see this 6 here and then the
value is incremented so after line 15
the value becomes 7 so that's how we are
basically using the unary operators
equality and relational operators when
we talk about relational operators they
are sometimes also called comparison
operators and the basic idea behind
using these operators is to compare
things or compare the value
of variables or compare the objects in
Java so in Java if you need to compare
anything for example if you want to
compare if something is less than the
other thing or something is greater than
the other thing or something is equal to
the other thing then you need to use the
comparison operators which are provided
by Java here you can see I have opened
the official Java docs and you can see a
bunch of comparison or relational
operators both of the terms are used
interchangeably some people call them
comparison operators and some people
call them relational operators so you
can see if I want to compare if an
object or a value is equal to another
value then I use the double equal sign
if I want to compare for non-equality I
will use exclamation with an equal to
which means not equal to if I want to do
a greater than comparison then I will
use the mathematics greater than symbol
if I want to do the greater than equal
to or or less than or less than equal to
they again follow the same kind of
terminology as we see in mathematics so
this is all we have in terms of the
relational operators so let's understand
the usage of these operators with the
help of some examples so as you can see
I have created a class here which is
called comparison operator there is a
public static wide main method inside
this class and this method has two
variables of integer type called value 1
and value 2 value 1 has a value 1 and
value 2 has the value 2 and then I am
trying to compare the value 1 and value
2 variables using the different
relational operators we just covered for
doing that I need to use a conditional
operator as well we will be covering
conditional operators in much much
detail in the upcoming lectures but for
now you can understand that when we talk
about conditional operators we talk
about if an else statement so f is again
a keyword in Java which can be used to
compare things and the syntax is very
straightforward you write the if keyword
and then you write the actual comparison
syntax or the actual comparison
expression so in the first example we
can see that I am writing a condition
which says evaluate if value 1 is equal
to Value 2 I should put a curly braces
around here you can see there are no
curly brushes here but that is for a
case when you have only one statement
under it but again I will cover this in
detail and I don't want to confuse the
audience here so I will just put curly
braces around all of these if statements
so that it becomes easy to interpret
what is actually going on in these code
blocks as we know that these curly
brushes are used to define a code block
so the first if block says compare if
the value 1 is equal to the value 2 if
yes then this condition will become 2
and the control of the program will go
at line number 10. if this condition is
not true then the control will not go
inside 10 because this condition is
false so it will never go to line 10 and
it will move to line 11 or 12 instead
similarly the next condition is we are
comparing the value 1 is not equal to
Value 2. so this condition will only be
true if these two values are not equal
or unequal and if that is the case then
line 14 will execute it otherwise line
14 will not be executed similarly in
this condition I am saying compare if
value 1 is greater than value 2 or not
so if the actual value hold it by value
1 variable is greater than the value 2
variable then this condition will become
true and the line 18 will be executed
otherwise it will be skipped then
similarly at line 20 I am doing the
reverse I am comparing if value 1 is
less than equal less than value 2 if
that is the case then line 22 will be
executed otherwise it will be skipped
and At Last I am also showcasing an
example of less than equal to operator
that you put less than and equal to
together and again you compare the two
variables similarly you can also use
greater than equal to variable
comparison operator as well in this
example so we have an example of
equality not equal to greater than less
than and less than equal to let's run
this example to understand so for
running the example I will just right
click here go to run as and click on
Java application and we can see the
output here so as the value 1 holds the
value 1 and value 2 variable holds the
value 2 obviously 1 is not equal to 2 so
the first condition is not going to be
evaluated to true so line 10 will never
be executed because 1 is not equal to 2.
similarly if I talk about the next
condition which was if value 1 is not
equal to Value 2 then execute statement
40 and yes 1 is not equal to 2 that's
why we see this particular system dot
out dot println here we see this printed
moving on is value 1 greater than value
2 so is 1 greater than 2 no it's not so
line 18 will never be executed then the
next one is is value 1 less than value 2
so yes 1 is less than 2 so line 22 will
be executed and we see the line 22
output here system dot out dot print and
output moving on is 1 less than equal to
2 yes 1 is less than equal to 2 so this
particular condition is also true and
line 26 will be executed and that's why
we see this here and that's all so we
can see that we are able to use these
comparison or relational operators to
evaluate different conditions and we
write those conditions using the if
block and again if you do not understand
the if block fully don't worry we will
be covering the if blocks in detail but
the focus here is in using the operators
the not equal to operators the greater
than equal to operators less than equal
to operators Etc so I hope these
operators give you better understanding
of how to use them M now moving on to
the next section of this comparison
operators sometimes we also use some
logical terms to do the comparison for
example if I just move down here and I
show you these conditions here we call
them conditional operators conditional
operators are used to evaluate the
conditions like and or or and we use
them in two two ways either we can use
it as Ampersand or double Ampersand or
we can use them as pipe or double pipes
so the idea is basically to evaluate if
one condition is true and other
condition is also true or one condition
is true or other condition is true so
whenever you want to combine two
conditions together that's where you're
going to use these logical operators or
conditional operators you can also use
the simple English keywords like and or
or you can use the logical
representation of these keywords for
example Ampersand Ampersand or double
Ampersand is equivalent to to add
similarly double pipe is equivalent to
or so we can use these as well
interchangeably you can use either of
these operator representations to run a
conditional check in composition meaning
you can compare two conditions saying
okay if one is true and second is true
or one is true or second is true so the
whole focus is here in and and or
comparisons so let's switch back to the
IDE and let's look at an example of this
to understand this in detail so I will
again take the similar kind of example
again I have created two variables here
value one and value 2 value 1 has value
as 1 and second variable value 2 has
value as 2 and then I am writing two
conditions this time in the same if
block you can see I am writing first
condition saying is value 1 equal to
equal to 1 and is value 2 also equal to
equal to 2 so this whole if condition is
only going to be true only if both of
the conditions are true that's the
property of and and will force that both
the conditions on the left hand side of
it and the right hand side of it hold
true and then only the whole expression
is going to hold true even if one of the
conditions evaluate to false the whole
if expression will evaluate to false
similarly for or conditions we again
write a left hand condition and a right
hand condition and in between we write
this double pipe we can also write o r
or in English that will also have the
same effect and this will evaluate in a
way that this whole expression this
whole expression will evaluate to true
if even a single condition either on
left side or right side of it becomes
true so or we'll just need one
expression to be true to make the whole
if condition true whereas and will force
both of the conditions to be true to
make the whole expression as true so and
will require two truths to actually
become true but our condition will
require only one true to become true so
if we try to do uh understand this logic
here I am saying that if value 1 is
equal to equal to 1 which is correct and
value 2 is equal to equal to 2 then make
this condition as true so yes in this
case this condition will evaluate to
true because value 1 has value 1 1 and
value 2 has value as 2 so it will print
the line 10 whereas in the next
condition I'm saying evaluate if value 1
is equal to equal to 1 or value 2 is
equal to equal to 1. so either of the
expression if becomes true either the
left side this expression or the right
side this expression either of the
expression becomes true this whole
condition will become true and line 14
will be executed line 14 will not be
executed only in a case when both of the
conditions here become false for example
sample if I write it like this then we
know that value 1 is not equal to 4
because it's 1 and value 2 is not equal
to 5 because it's true in that case both
of the expression will become false and
then line 14 will not be executed if I
write it like this then the left hand
expression is evaluated to true because
value 1 is 1 but the right hand
expression is false but it's fine the
line 14 will still be executed because
either of these side is true so the
whole expression becomes true similarly
here and will require both of the
Expressions to be true and if either of
them becomes false then whole expression
becomes false so in the current state
line 10 will be executed but if I change
this to this then the left hand side of
this Ampersand will evaluate to false
and the whole expression will evaluate
to false in that case and line 10 will
never be executed let's try to run all
of these scenarios to make a better
understanding of this so in this case
both of the conditions should work fine
so I will just right click and run as
Java application and yes we see this
line 10 being printed and we also see
this line 13 being printed so both of
the lines are printed correctly both of
the conditions are evaluating to true
now let's try to play around with it let
me change this value to 4 so now value 1
this left hand side expression is false
which should make the whole expression
is false and it should not print the
line 10 which is the statement so let's
run this program and see if that works
yes we see that this particular line is
not printed now because this whole
expression became false because the left
hand side of this expression became
false similarly in the r case either of
them has to have to be true you can see
currently value 2 equal to equal to 5
condition will actually result in a
false condition because this is not a
true value 2 is actually two not five
and still we see this particular
expression because either of them have
to be true if I make both of them as not
true now both of the conditions on the
left hand side of pipe and right hand
side of pipe are false conditions what
will happen now nothing will be printed
the reason for that is that value 1 is
also that this condition is also false
and value 2 condition is also false so
the whole expression became false and
this was already false bitwise operators
now bitwise operators are very less
commonly used in the Java programming
World generally we don't use them and
generally we don't need to use them you
would generally use them when you are
doing really complex bitwise calculation
where you need to manipulate the bits
now what are actually bits so if you
remember when we talked about the
integer type variables we talked about
how much memory each of the variable
type or data type was going to consume
we said that this will take one byte and
this will take two bytes Etc one byte is
basically made up of eight bits and bits
are nothing but positions where either a
0 is stored or one is stored actually
the whole machine will convert your
whole program ultimate directly in zeros
and ones which are nothing but bits so
if you want to do the manipulation at
that level so now you can understand you
are you are actually working at right at
the Machine level understanding so if
you want to manipulate the bits which
are going to be understood by the
machine at that level then you can use
bitwise operators but like I said
generally we don't need to use them now
when we talk about bitwise operators
there are multiple ways in which we can
use them we can use them with the
standard and or or operations if you
remember we covered this and or
operations in the previous lecture you
see a difference here that in case of
and we are using a single Ampersand or
and not double Ampersand this is one of
the concept which we did not cover in
the previous lecture and I would just
like to brief you about this concept
that if you use double Ampersand that is
also called a short circuit operator and
if you use a single Ampersand that is
called a standard operator to build an
understanding about this I will just
quickly recap of what we covered in the
last lecture and we'll try to explain
these Concepts as well so let's go to
The Logical operator demo and here if
you remember there were two ampersands
and two pipes this is also a valid
expression a single Ampersand is also a
valid expression the only change is in
this case even if the left hand
condition evaluates to false still the
right hand condition will be evaluated
although we know that in case of and
either of the expression needs to be
false and the whole expression becomes
false so Java provides an advantage or
with that if you use double Ampersand
and if the left hand operation becomes
false then it will not cover the right
hand operation it will not even evaluate
the right hand operation because it
doesn't matter if the left hand
operation has already returned to false
or evaluated to false then no matter
whether right side is true or false the
whole expression is is still going to be
false right that's the property of and
one of the side has to be false and the
whole expression becomes false so why
why evaluate two sides why waste the
memory in evaluating the right side when
the left side has already turned as
false Java takes advantage of that and
that's why if you use double Ampersand
you save a bit of processing power of
your computer by just evaluating the
left hand condition and if the left hand
condition is false it will skip
evaluating the right hand condition and
just make the whole expression false but
if you use this a single n percent then
both side of the expression will be
evaluated irrespective of their output
so in this case even if the left hand
expression is false it is still going to
evaluate the right side expression and
similarly it works for the or case as
well in this case in our case as we know
if one of the condition is true the
whole condition becomes true the whole
expression becomes true so if the left
hand side becomes true and if you use a
single pipe then it will still evaluate
the right hand side but if you use
double pipe like this then if the left
hand side becomes true then it knows
that it does not matter if the right
hand side becomes true or false because
ultimately the whole expression is going
to be true if either of the side is true
so if the left hand side is already true
it will not evaluate the right hand side
and it will say the whole expression is
true that's why you see the single
Ampersand being used for bitwise just to
explain why it why it is used and how it
is used for our operations in bitwise
you use this cap or whatever you want to
call it as and for the inclusive bitwise
or opera or operation we are going to
use a single pipe you also use some
shift operations where you shift the
value of bit of a particular variable to
either left or right again these are
again very complex calculations if you
want to use that please read about this
and use that but in the in today's demo
what we are going to cover is the and
and or examples of bitwise operations
so here I have again created a class
called bitwise operator I have a public
static void main method I have two
variables here which are int a equal to
5 and int b equal to 7. now these five
and seven are actually stored as bits as
zeros and ones in the computer's memory
so how they are actually stored they are
stored in a standard bit representation
which you may have uh studied in your
mathematics if to give your recap this 5
will basically be written in a memory as
this 0 1 0 1 and it starts from here 2
raised to power 0 into 1 becomes 1 2
raised to power 1 into 0 becomes 0 2
raised to power 2 into 1 becomes 4 and 2
raised to power 3 into 0 becomes 0 so 4
0 plus 4 plus 0 plus 1 becomes 5 and
that's how 5 is displayed to you
similarly for 7 2 raised to power 0 into
1 is 1 the plus 2 raised to power 1 into
1 is 2 so 1 plus 2 3 plus 2 raised to
power 2 into 1 which is 4 so 1 plus 2
plus 4 7 and 2 raised to power 3 into 0
is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is
7 and that's how this 7 is built and
stored and now if you try to do this if
you try to write this condition you can
also write the condition into a system
dot out dot println block and it will
basically evaluate this condition so now
if you say A and B in this case this is
going to do a bit wise operation because
this is bitwise operand it is going to
do a bit wise operation and the what
would be the result if you do an and on
this so again use the same logic as if
in case of and if one is false then the
whole expression is false so 0 and 0
becomes 0 1 and 1 becomes 1 0 and 1
becomes 0 because 0 means false and 1
means true so if either of them is false
the whole evaluation becomes false so
that's why 0 or and 1 becomes 0 and 1
and 1 is always one the value of this is
again 5 as we already have evaluated
similarly if you do a bit wise or and if
you do this again we are doing an R
operation so 0 or 0 or basically false
or false becomes false true or true
becomes true false or true should be
true because one of them needs to be
true so this is false but this is true
so the whole value becomes true and the
finally true or true is also true so
this is the final bitwise or result and
if we convert this into an integer
representation that becomes 7 because 2
raised to power 0 into 1 is 1 2 raised
to power 1 into 1 is 2 so 2 plus 1 3
plus 2 raised to the power 2 into 1
which is 4 so 4 plus 2 plus 1 which is 7
and plus 2 raised to power 3 into 0
which is 0 so 0 plus 4 plus 2 plus 1
becomes 7 and that's how you get
actually 7. so let's see if we get 5 or
7 in this bit wise operation yes we can
see the values as 5 and 7. so this is a
bitwise operation happening similarly
you can also use the shift operations
where in case if you're using the this
particular kind of representation or
this particular kind of representation
they are called bits they are called
left shift and right shift operations so
if you use this in front of a variable
then for example this one will be
shifted here and this 0 will be shifted
here and this one will be shifted here
so that's how the whole value is going
to shift all bits are going to shift one
by one towards left similarly if you are
using the right shift then all the bits
are going to be shifted towards right by
one bit that's the whole concept of left
shift and right shift bitwise operations
and if you want to know more about this
please read some official examples from
the Java Doc and some other examples
available on the internet to build an
understanding on this and with that we
have come to the end of this tutorial on
operators in Java I hope you guys must
have got a good idea about what
operators are and how to use them in
Java if you feel that we have missed out
on some important topic that we were
supposed to cover in this video then
please feel free to drop them down in
the comment section below and the team
of experts will definitely answer them
for you so thank you so much for being
here guys today we'll see you next time
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign